[Música]
mi abuelo andrés nació en una vereda del
municipio de vélez en santander y al
igual que todos los muchachos pues
disfrutaba ayudando en las labores del
hogar y jugando y estudiando resulta que
uno de esos días donde estaba ayudando a
batir la guayaba para producir el
bocadillo después de 18 horas de estar
allí a tanto calor lo enviaron a llevar
un pedido a un pueblo vecino
y durante el trayecto le cayó un fuerte
aguacero
a lo que él no le dio mucha importancia
sin embargo dos semanas después empezó a
sentir que la mano se le dormían que
estaba perdiendo la sensibilidad en su
cuerpo y que unas manchas rosadas
estaban apareciendo por su piel
eso sí le preocupó y se lo comunicó de
una vez a la mamá ella habló con un
médico amigo de la familia y le pidió
que llevara al muchacho para hacerle
unos exámenes y unas pruebas
una semana después el médico llamó a la
señora y le dijo su merced
el muchacho lo que tienes lepra
lepra lepra esas palabras calaron en la
señora y cayeron como un baldado de agua
fría inmediatamente se puso a llorar y
sollozando llegó a su casa con el marido
sacaron las cositas que tenía andrés la
cama y la ropa donde él comía y lo
llevaron para la pieza de los chiles
al día siguiente llegó la policía y
traslado a andrés desde su vereda hasta
el lazareto de contratación
al llegar al lazareto encontró que
habían unos retenes en esos retenes
estaba la policía custodiando los
retenes existían nueve alrededor de todo
el lazareto para que los enfermos no se
si no se pudieran escapar de ahí y las
electores del lugar para albergar a los
enfermos de lepra después en los retenes
pues lo recibió una policía sana y la
policía lo trasladó hasta una casa
grande que había que denominaba en la
administración en esa casona lo
reseñaron y le cambiaron las monedas que
él traía la plata que él traía se la
cambiaron por monedas que únicamente
circulaban dentro del contexto del
lazareto
además de eso le tomaron fotos y le
hicieron el documento de identidad
la cédula parecía una libretica y si
sería su identificación por el resto de
sus días
después de esto pues andrés que es un
poco como confundido llegó la policía
enferma y la llevó para el interior del
poblado y allí lo ubicaron cuando yo
digo policía enferma y policía sana es
que hay adentro en el contexto el que es
enfermo de lepra se le dice el enfermo y
el que no la tiene es el sano y así con
todas las personas
resulta que
después de que suben el lazareto se
ubicó fácilmente e hizo amigos todos
tenían la misma enfermedad y rápidamente
aprendió la labor de la sastrería
aprendió a jugar tejo se enamoró a los 4
años se casó de esa unión tuvo una hija
mi mamá
y así fue pasando el tiempo resulta que
bueno todo era color de rosa sin embargo
llegó un día una ley del gobierno que
decía que por obligación todos los hijos
de los enfermos deberían ir a asilos
empezó el trauma llegaron el corregidor
era el que dirigía la policía la interna
y llegaron y a la casa de mi abuelo se
llevaron a mi mamá para el asilo maría
auxiliadora que quedaba ubicado en otro
municipio en guadalupe en santander
resulta que una vecina tenía un niño
también eran sanos a los celos a los
sanos los llevaban a asilos para sanos y
a los niños que eran enfermos asilos
para enfermos
el niño era sano se lo llevaron para el
asilo san bernardo que quedaba ubicado
en el municipio de guacamayo también en
santander resulta que la mamá de este
niño si no aguantó el hecho que lo
llevaran ella gritaba corría por las
calles como loca llegó a la casa se
roció gasolina y se incendió eso marcó
un trauma en la población durante muchos
años todo esto ocurría porque resulta
que colombia se estaba llenando de
leprosos decía el gobierno y que eso
estaba perjudicando la comercialización
de sus productos con otros países de tal
manera que el gobierno tomó la
determinación de dividir a colombia en
tres distritos el distrito número uno
correspondía a la parte
nor oriental de colombia
el lugar donde deberían ir todos los
enfermos que aparecieran allí era a
contratación el distrito número 2 estaba
ubicado en la parte norte de colombia
eso quería decir que todos los enfermos
que aparecieran en esa zona tenían que
ir a caño el oro que estaba ubicado en
cartagena después lo pasaron para la
isla de tierrabomba tierrabomba fue
bombardeado en el año 1955 por la fuerza
aérea colombiana pero previamente le
trasladaron a los enfermos paraguay dio
sí para contratación y el distrito
número 3 abarcaba toda la parte sur
occidental de colombia y el enfermo que
apareciera en esa zona debería ser
trasladado por obligación agua de dios
resulta que
el médico noruego llegar a amargar
hansen descubrió la forma de controlar
el bacilo que producía la lepra se
llamaba microbacterial leprae y una vez
se supo cómo se podría controlar se
acabaron los lazaretos en colombia fue
el año en 1961 el gobierno sacó una ley
donde decía que abolido si empezaban a
ser municipios común y corriente con
todos los derechos que tenía cualquier
municipio de este país sin embargo pues
para la gente que habitaba en el pueblo
eso no fue una solución si alguien venía
aquí a bogotá y decía que era de
contratación estaba marcado por ese
estigma y entonces nadie quería decir
que era el pueblo de igual manera habían
muchas restricciones que hacían que la
gente no quisiera volver también al
lugar
o sea el hecho de ser que de
contratación nos había marcado para
siempre
nosotros tuvimos una época en la que se
manejó siempre eso la población había
disminuido también bastante y en el año
de 1981 llegaron los salesianos hablaron
con mi abuelo eso primero hablaban entre
ellos para pedirle que por favor me
dejaran a mí de profesor allá en el
pueblo yo era menor de edad entonces
tenía que contar con el aval me agua él
me decía mi abuelo me decía mire mi hijo
la educación es la única herramienta que
nos va a permitir cambiar la historia y
yo le creí
cuando empecé a ser profesor mi abuelo
murió a los 6 a los 6 meses de que era
profesor cuando empecé pues primero yo
decía bueno las problemáticas que hay
que los muchachos no quieren hablar con
los padres de familia la gente no quiere
volver al pueblo el sentido de
pertenencia por el lugar no existe la
visión que tenemos sobre el lugar no
existe entonces como desde la educación
podría uno cambiar eso
y empezamos a implementar diferentes
estrategias primero creamos una
especialidad técnica llamada informática
y comunicaciones el colegio era técnico
pero cuando fuimos a buscar los
patrocinios y todos nadie quería
apoyarnos como se les ocurre que van a
cambiar las máquinas de escribir por
computador eso no cabe en ninguna cabeza
y así es como 20 problemas pero ni una
solución y acudimos a todos los que
tenían la plata que la alcaldía que el
consejo de todas maneras buscamos el
apoyo en ongs internacionales y de una
de sales y admisión nos regalaron 10 mil
dólares y eso fueron el inicio de lo que
somos hoy en día y con eso empezamos a
hacer cosas como éstas por ejemplo
empezamos a crear enciclopedias
interactivas para que los niños más
pequeños pudieran aprender de la
historia del lazareto creamos un canal
de televisión con los estudiantes donde
invitamos a los enfermos a que nos
contarán su historia y nosotros la
dramatiza vamos también y un periódico
para dar a conocer todo lo que se vivía
en el contexto del lazareto y que toda
la gente se fuera
enterando de muchas cosas que ellos
habían vivido y que no sabían
y eso pues eso fue hace 20 años lo el
periódico hacia 8 años está en internet
todos los meses lo sacamos con los
muchachos
creamos blogs para que la gente que no
era contratación empezara a sentir como
esas ganas de conocer el municipio y su
historia después empezamos con las redes
sociales también al crear álbumes de tal
manera que ellos pudieran reconocerse en
esas imágenes y escribir ahí los pies de
fotos eso creó una gran sinergia y él
nos ayudó bastante y ximo a que la gente
se empezara a enamorar del pueblo
nuevamente para que los muchachos
pudieran hablar con los papás nos
inventamos el árbol genealógico 3 cada
uno tenía que hablar con su papá con la
mamá para que ellos le dijeran quién era
el abuelo el bisabuelo así todo eso y
después lo llevábamos a un libro virtual
todo utilizando las tics en un libro
virtual empezamos a decir bueno quiénes
fueron los primeros de su generación
cómo vinieron acá qué anécdotas tuvieron
ustedes cómo nacieron cómo se visualizan
dentro de cinco o diez años después de
que salgan del colegio
eso nos ayudó muchísimo en el colegio se
crea una gran empatía por esta historia
después de todo esto
bueno lo presentamos a concursos tuvimos
cualquier cantidad de reconocimiento
nacional e internacional pero después
dijimos bueno y para dónde vamos
excelente todo lo que hemos hecho pero
ahora que y nos pusimos a estudiar con
los muchachos qué posibilidades habían
de inventar de un proyecto a lo grande o
sea un sueño yo decía no seguimos porque
ticos teníamos a lo grande y nos
imaginamos la contratación como el
primer parque histórico cultural del
mundo en homenaje al enfermo de hansen y
eso como se podría hacer y empezamos a
buscar todas las todas las estrategias
que nos permitirían llegar a ese ideal y
esas estrategias eran por ejemplo de
crear museos que crear parques que
revivir las calles con nombres de
personas que hubieran hecho si fueran
significativas para la época en lazareto
de crear esculturas también en homenaje
de personajes y revivir la moneda como
un atractivo turístico crear la cátedra
de memoria histórica para el colegio
y en fin muchas cosas que nosotros
plasmamos en un blog también ese blog lo
dimos a conocer en la red por allá de
japón nos invitaron a socializarlo la
fundación sasakawa jeal fundation nos
invitó a darlo a conocer a 16 países que
también habían sufrido del flagelo de la
lepra y ahora bueno cómo vamos en agosto
en agosto inauguraron las primeras
cuatro esculturas son las que están ahí
que representan personajes que fueron
simbólicos para nuestra época para la
época del lazareto además ya se
aprobaron los planos se hizo la
licitación y ya están los dineros para
construir la casa de la cultura donde
van a alojar los los museos de igual
manera ya nos aprobaron dentro del pei
curricular la implementación de la
cátedra de memoria histórica con
muchachos del grado décimo y undécimo
estamos empezando a hacer las cartillas
de manera cronológica para que sean
aplicadas en cada uno de los grados y
que les sirva pues más a los a quien a
los profesores para que tengan como una
ruta de trabajo
ahora yo quiero invitarlos a que ustedes
tomen un origami que debe estar en sus
maletas por ahí y es que en ese origami
está toda la historia que les conté hoy
está elaborado sobre sobre una base en
papel y en ese papel está la figura que
está ahí en sus pantallas para que
ustedes no lo desbarate está la figurita
de esa y no les voy a decir más o menos
lo que representan en torno a la
experiencia que les conté y para que
ustedes lo vayan asociando con sus
propias vidas uno en la vida también
tiene momentos oscuros la clave es no
quedarse ahí sino visualizar algo mejor
y eso mejor se hace a través de unos
pasos de euros criterios nosotros
hicimos esto sobre esa base que está ahí
para simbolizar como la parte negra del
lazareto lo que se vivió después con los
estudiantes del grado 10º y 11º lo
convertimos en este origami que podría
ser un barquito podría ser
bueno cualquier cosa para nosotros es
como algo como un signo
de todas maneras lo importante era que
esto fuera un sueño
y yo quiero decirles que ya estamos
logrando lo que nos proponemos y que eso
que una vez fue terrible para nosotros
en el futuro con esa visión que nosotros
tenemos va a ser la salvación para
muchas familias que van a vivir del
turismo histórico cultural
por eso quiero terminar con estas dos
palabras que son bueno un homenaje a mi
abuelo porque esa frase nunca se me va a
olvidar y con la educación sí se puede
segundo porque son la razón por la que
estoy aquí hoy frente a ustedes y
tercero porque en la magia que me
inspira para seguir adelante esas dos
palabras son viva contratación gracias